welcome I'm Matthew Spalding I'm the
associate dean assuming of the associate
vice president Dean for Hillsdale
College here in Washington DC as you
know the main campus is out in Michigan
and this is or Washington DC presence
for those of you have not been here
before I extended a special welcome to
the Allenby kirby center for
constitutional studies and citizenship
we have a great day some great things
going on here we have a few sessions
this morning with one with my cell phone
John Miller who is running our
journalism programs on campus this
afternoon you have a tour when you're
coming back for the dedication of our
radio studio on the fourth floor from
which Hugh Hewitt is broadcasting doing
our inaugural broadcast then there are
some tours this afternoon if you've not
been here you should torrent see this
facility if you have been here before
you should still turenne see the
facility because we've made some
significant changes both in terms of the
classrooms some office spaces the radio
studio especially and some other things
here in the building when you come to
this building one of the first things
you recognize hopefully is the
difference this place has in terms of
its look that's by design if you go to
the campus in Hillsdale you will see the
same pattern we believe that the look of
a place it's architecture design helps
point towards the thing that you are
emphasizing and here it's intended to do
so pointing towards the great things we
teach when you go around Washington see
dr. Oren likes to point out the ugliest
buildings are usually the ones that are
the most unconstitutional
which which is very true I've been here
for some time and you go around and look
at these absolutely atrocious buildings
one of the worst of course being the
Department of Education which is which
is purely Stalin esque it's it's just
very square and and and and faceless the
opposite of that of course is the fact
that all the most beautiful buildings
Tim intend to be the ones that perhaps
not currently mind you but in but in
terms of how they are designed aren't
designed for a purpose I always point
this out to my students and and
especially younger visitors you don't
necessarily notice these things but the
US Capitol is a great example that the
Supreme Court and the National Archives
all of those buildings although now
because of the Department of Homeland
Security they've changed this which is
another don't give me out going on that
one but all those buildings are designed
so that you you you walk up to the
entrance you go upstairs which say it
forces you to raise your horizon and
raise your perspective so that you are
approaching and going up to these great
monuments of democracy especially true
when you go to the archives building if
you've not visited there recently or at
all it's designed as a model modeled on
the Parthenon in Rome or of course the
Romans kept the gods they had captured
from those they had defeated that's not
what we use the art parthenon for our
national archives contains our
declaration in our Constitution this
building is meant to evoke the
seriousness with which we pursue our
work here in Washington DC and what we
what we teach well have more to say
about that this evening
but this place is an extension of the
college an extension of its teaching
mission and so you come here and you see
this beautiful facility it's not a think
tank it's not a law firm it's not the
Department of Education far from that
and you come in here to this wonderful
room and many speakers we've had here
come to this marvelous room and be taken
by very much so and you see this
wonderful painting behind me signing of
the Constitution and Sam connect on
campus our art teacher or art artists
did this painting and on the last day
September 17 1787 just before the
signing of the Constitution this is the
culmination of much work 11 years since
the Declaration independence 25 years
since the end of the french and indian
war about a 180 years since Jamestown
and much longer of course since if you
want to go back all the way through the
influence of British constitutionalism
Magna Carta going back to 1215 if you
one of the greatest turning points in
human history and here they are
celebrating that culminating moment you
have and we have information and our
website and a pamphlet if you want to
see more detail of it the Pennsylvania
delegation is over here although we can
see Benjamin Franklin seated in the
middle back in that back corner from the
New England delegations over here the
three in the corner these are the three
that didn't sign the Constitution Gary
and Randolph of course did that the to
the one here in the corner George Mason
farthest in the corner never accrued
didn't sign it also never approved the
Constitution later
Alexander Hamilton in the gold waistcoat
here but of course the very design of
the painting the angle is directed
towards the two in the middle those two
particular figures and this this
culminating event is largely results of
the collaborative work of all of these
individuals but especially those two and
they're all different Hamilton's the
brash young man the bull in the china
cabinet many ways brilliant when it
comes to economics washington's 55 years
old general the army there's another
painting in the back of the room also by
the same artist that shows you to scale
the height difference at his death
washington is either 63 perhaps 62 63 a
little taller even but he's robust
natural leader he embodies the very
principles of the American Founding hit
a knack for choosing great men Jefferson
who's not in this picture for which we
are ever thankful he's over in France
the times he's not at the Constitution
pension the other one who's not here is
John Adams for which we are ever
thankful probably those two would have
potentially prevented this from being
successful but the other one at the
center of the painting is a diminutive
small man 54 much younger 36 years old
frail tend to be sickly very quiet and
that of course is James Madison today
when we speak of individuals we talk
about leadership that's the word of the
day we hear tend to speak and like to
saw talk about statesmanship there's a
profound difference between those two
things and one of the essential things
we wish to teach our students
the public who are looking at these
things going on today and of course
those who are actually leading is to
take this other view leadership some
modern idea actually comes from the
progressives we'll come back to in a
moment the ID of leadership is you are
leading along a path but you're
following something else they're great
analogy is the idea of kind of following
history on the river as it goes down the
stream but statesmanship is a different
thing it's a classical idea goes back to
the ancient it the idea is it is that
you have a permanent thing which you
have as your objective that gives you a
sense of where you're going and you
oriented all of your politics towards
that thing the classical knowledge you
see in Aristotle and cicero and all the
other classical writers is the idea of a
ship on the sea you guide yourself by
the stars by the permanent things to
help you give you that sense of
direction to Washington the file of the
country Madison the father the
Constitution Hamilton Franklin Franklin
is gesturing towards the two in the
center there North Star was this this
culminating event the preservation of
this thing the perpetuation of it all
the work that taught took them to get
there and yet we must remember that just
months before this event and those years
before this event going back to the
Declaration the end of the french and
indian war and the years before that it
was not at all clear that this event
would be successful indeed if anything
it was actually quite doubtful what they
reflect and why we study them and why we
look back to them not as merely
historical figures
but as examples for today is that
statesmanship what they produced their
culminating North Star is precisely what
is at stake today not the document not
the piece of paper not the historical
idea of it but the larger question they
ask begin to the Federalist Papers which
is can we govern ourselves and if so how
can we design a regime by which man can
govern themselves and allow for
sufficient freedom for them to pursue
their happiness and can we perpetuate it
to do so as then so today we'll take
statesmanship individuals who had deep
since the principles and where they're
going and are clever and strategic and
thoughtful about how to get there let me
say a few things about America and then
I come back to our friends the
progressives and then talk about some of
our dilemmas today because it Hillsdale
we teach and our curriculum or work is
centered around the liberal arts which
is say centered around learning the
permanent things literature history but
the key difference is you learn those
permanent things so you can know how to
do and live your life according to them
today which demands a perspective above
then but also now what's different about
this country is not just the fact that
it's ours but it makes certain and
different claims certain claims about
principles about these very things that
direct the statesman
we see the most famously of course in
the declaration independence this idea
that all men are created equal they're
dowd by their creator with certain
unalienable rights that our perspective
on politics and our lives should be
oriented towards a recognition of the
laws of nature and of nature's God we
speak a lot today and you hear
candidates constantly talk about
American exceptionalism I'm not sure
they quite understand the sense of which
America is exceptional it has to do with
these deeper groundings we talk a lot
about first principles the word
principle is an old Latin word first
coined by Cicero but it comes from the
use of the Roman legions that is when
the Romans made their encampments they
put at the center of their encampment
all the symbols and flags of Rome to
signify what they fought for and that
place was called a Principia from which
Cicero got the word principles this
unique sense of the American Founding
the idea that we have a founding itself
a classical idea France doesn't have a
founding Germany does have a founding
America's our founding it's oriented
towards these core principles of human
Liberty of the idea that we are equal
and that equality is grounded in
something other than merely a claim
prior to the American Founding people
were subjects which meant you were
subject to the king are some other
authority there was no such thing as
citizenship citizenship the idea of
modern citizenship begins when these
Americans informed by other thought
going all the way back to the Greeks and
Romans
sure but the Americans for the first
time decided to build a country based on
this idea and build their laws around it
and from this idea there are rights
grounded in nature that we equally
possess as humans no one is worn as
Jefferson like to say booted and spurred
none with the saddle on his back we are
equal and because we're equal the only
way to proceed the only fair way to
proceed is to the consent of the
governed the two great rights of the
American Founding there are others but
they were only interested in they only
wanted to secure the most important and
significant of them one is the floor and
one is a sealing the floor is a claim of
property you have your property which
say you may own and sell I mean acquire
by virtue the fact you have mixed your
labor with it and because of that it
becomes yours you've mix it with a sweat
of your brow it's the first principle
Liberty the ceiling then is religious
liberty religious freedom you have a
right to pursue your relationship with
the divine in the ancient world your
gods were the gods of your city Sparta
or Athens and when your city was
defeated your gods were defeated this is
of course changes with Judaism
Christianity but the Americans
Washington famously says I took to the
field for the sake of civil and
religious liberty the Americans had a
different idea that you each because of
your human nature had a fundamental
right to your religious freedom
there's a second set of ideas that we
wrap around the Constitution we are all
created equal and we all can consent to
the governed how then do you do that it
took them 11 years to get there they had
to go through the artist Confederation
but they eventually came to the
constitution of course in doing so they
had inherited the rule of law from the
British it predates the American
Founding it goes back for we adjusted
that the British have no written
constitution one of the reasons why
Britain is in such a bad shape it's
precisely because once their laws have
changed their laws are merely the slow
evolution of time it's very hard to turn
them back we insisted on a written
constitution by virtue of the
Declaration we possess rights governed
some really possessed powers we see that
in the opening clauses of the
Constitution power is delegated by
virtue of those rights and furthermore
those powers are all separated divided
tect and balanced james madison the
other founders federalist papers tell us
don't rely on parchment barriers look to
its structure the parchment barriers are
not enough and so he designed auxiliary
precautions representation federalism
the separation of powers all the things
to secure our independence so that we
could be self-governing and pursue
happiness one of my favorite stories
that I found a long ago and I put in one
of my previous books was a story of a
young man named Levi Levi Preston he
serves the Battle of Concord goes to
this point
he's later interviewed by a historian
who wants to know why did you go fire
the Battle of Concord you're fighting
against the greatest and most powerful
military force in the world and he went
to the Battle of Concord untrained with
a gun left over from French and Indian
War small number of people against a
large contingent of the British coming
from Boston through Lexington where the
first shots had been fired why did you
fire the Battle of Concord the historian
asked me by Preston surely objected
objected to the Tea Tax I didn't drink
tea he said then it was a stamp act you
objected to the Stamp Act having to pay
your taxes and show a stamp I didn't
object that much to that as well didn't
bother me that much well surely you read
all those books those books of
Republican theory I didn't read those
said Levi Preston I read the Bible and
then Psalms what was it the historian
wanting to know flustered very simple
said Levi Preston we had always governed
ourselves we intended to do so and those
redcoats didn't think that we should I
like that story because to my students
it points out we don't have hindsight
neither de Levi Preston we have x look
backward to find explanations about
history but especially important to
point out for him it was a very simple
idea that we wanted to govern ourselves
the argument to the American Founding
this idea of Rights expressed in the
Declaration grouted in nature giving
rise to consent and constitutionalism of
its particular structure it's
complicated way Madison designs all of
that today is precisely is what is
debated at the time of the founding up
through the end of the 19th century
through the Civil War it was a consensus
the civil wars fought over that it's the
great exception that proves the rule
Jefferson and Hamilton they debated
everything and they discreet about
everything but they agreed on the most
important things you can't find a
writing of Hamilton's on the rights of
man that is any less beautiful than the
greatest writings of Jefferson it was
after the civil war that this all
changes as is often the case people
started looking elsewhere the Civil War
the general opinion was happened because
the Constitution failed it hadn't worked
to prevent the Civil War we must look
elsewhere after the war that was the
beginnings of the Industrial Revolution
and the Constitution is a barrier
preventing change we must look elsewhere
and so they did many of them traveling
to Europe Britain France especially
Germany to find a new political science
that they could use to design a new way
of running government there they learn
many things studying with German
political thinkers I'll just mention two
one is there's no fixed truth anymore
this idea that politics can be based on
recognized self-evident truths makes no
sense Carl Becker a famous progressive
once wrote in a book about the
Declaration of Independence that to ask
whether the declaration is true or not
is a meaningless question and secondly
they talked about evolution in progress
by which they meant everything changes
not only there are no permanent fixed
truths but they're no contingent truths
for that matter they change over time
nice truths in the 19th century the 20th
century but they too will change the
idea of a fixed human nature debates
your politics on
the idea of property rights religious
liberty all of that is in question the
Constitution which was to be made into a
living document the origins of the idea
of the living Constitution come from
progressive jurisprudence and this
structure of the Constitution which
Madison and all the others talked about
at great length had to be changed in
favor of a new form of government which
they called and we sometimes now call
administration or more dramatically
bureaucracy there are much very much
enamored with the idea of science and
this science especially new Sciences
would lead us to better better excuse me
better and better ways to design things
to greater improvements to progress
progress with a capital P change in term
itself no coincidence that about this
time in 1860s is when Charles Darwin is
first writing about evolution the
progressives are studying in Europe and
Germany in the 1870s 1880s 1890s they
bring this home to begin the progressive
movement but as a result everything
needs to be rethought all the arguments
of the founders philosophical grounding
its practical design must all be
rethought this idea of administration
becomes a crucial element to that if man
has an equal nature his passions can
also be checked by government but
otherwise you wanna leave them is free
and possible to self-govern but if
science tells us that we can perfect
human nature and make it better what we
need are more and more people who have
been trained as experts to rule the
battle we face today is essentially a
battle between two graduates of
Princeton University James Madison
graduate from Princeton in 1771
started with John Witherspoon signer of
the Declaration Woodrow Wilson graduate
from Princeton 1879 the difference
between their two education is
fundamental Madison's was still within
the moral framework the moral horizon by
which the founders designed the
Constitution morally ground in the
principles of the Declaration Wilson
however is that the new progressive mind
we see this debate between the two
graduates Princeton playing out over the
course of the 20th century the
progressive move in the early part of
the century the New Deal but especially
the Great Society and things happening
the 1960s and 70s today I would suggest
to you many of the things we see and
find increasingly objectionable are the
fruits of all that that's not to say
that these ideas and this debate of
ideas plays out directly fits and starts
over time we have to understand its
grounding 1960s and 70s there was a turn
to this idea of administration once
again and more and more is thought that
things had to be done society widen
comprehensively clean the air clean the
water Congress or the course of the 20th
century increasingly delegated its
powers the powers in the Constitution to
regulators to those experts that the
progressives wanted legislation today of
course is a great example of all that
anyways much worse the ACA or Obamacare
the six of the economy but over a
hundred agencies run it little or
nothing occurs outside of that
regulation dodd-frank of course
financial regulations even worse
23 hundred pages if you ever read it
which I hope you do not these laws today
in many ways do not meet the classic
definition of law they are instructions
to rule makers dodd-frank is a perfect
example of that but it has one part the
Consumer Financial Protection Board
which is especially egregious it
contains its own funding mechanism it is
not subject to congressional oversight
and it has the power to interpret its
own regulations the point is this debate
between madison and wilson has come to a
place where we need to decide which
direction we wish to go the Madisonian
worlds is increasingly being overwhelmed
by a wilsonian world a few years ago
Congress passed on average about 200
laws only 50 of which were serious laws
got it yet it set aside all the Naimans
of post offices amounts to about 3,000
pages of law the same year regulators
put out eighty thousand pages of
regulations the fact that we speak today
about a new imperial presidency is
entirely predictable given how much
Congress has delegated and given away to
the administration giving presidents
much discretion now granted recent
presidents have learned to do it with or
without that discretion by amendment and
changing laws and perhaps even rewriting
them but the point is this is a new form
of governing governing by regulation
administration we faced two crises today
Abraham Lincoln one of his famous
speeches begins with the opening line if
we could only know where we are and
whether we are attending we would know
what to do and how to do it much simpler
said than done but this is where we are
and we are tending towards that way the
first crisis i think we face is which
ones which form of government will we be
ruled by this question of the
bureaucracy versus self government
bureaucracy increasingly encompass 'as
everything we of course think of debt
and spending and the trend we were on
there but it's hard to imagine today
something that is not covered by
bureaucracy in the regulatory state we
need to focus on that as the question of
our politics and I think that's how the
founders would look at it the end of
democracy America Tocqueville warns
actually of forms of soft despotism but
it has to do with us being ruled by
science and being less self-governing
but the second crisis i think we face is
how to think about it we often time tend
to be drawn towards legalistic ways of
looking at questions technical ways
looking for silver bullets and easy
fixes but these are fundamental regime
questions they're very definitional
about principle but we also find
yourselves in very difficult
circumstances here I think we actually
have a guide which is the Constitution
itself not as a legal document mind you
but as a framework not about its
parchment but because of its structure
if it's in its institutions its
coordinate branches
its powers and responsibilities checks
and balances we have a problem of an
imperial presidency we'd have a better
understanding of what the executive
power is but that imperial presidency is
largely responsible for us overlooking
oftentimes a complete Nutter collapse of
Congress that's the first branch the
first among equals the problem is that
no longer makes laws but that is its
rate duty and source of its powers it
has delegated too much over the years
over the decades and it needs to rain
regain its control there's especially
lost control of the budget process it
does things by continuing resolutions
now doesn't authorize and appropriating
more but also by rebuilding Congress you
shift authority to where individuals who
have been elected in a representative
can actually make practical decisions
about some of the hard questions we make
and you rebuild an institution which
increasingly can be a check against the
modern executive
doing so will require constitutional
strategies and statesmanship recall that
prudence is the classical virtue of
politics it's got a bad name today we
think of prudes but it's a virtue
courage another virtue has to be able to
balance between cowardice and foolhardy
pneus as prudence that dictates it's a
practical wisdom about contingent things
it sometimes is incremental think of how
Henry Clay the great States been dealt
with questions of slavery in the 19th
century but it's oftentimes and must of
necessity be very bold as well think of
Lincoln the founders themselves
Federalist one says that has been
reserved the people of this country by
their conduct an example to decide the
important question for the societies of
men are really capable of not or not of
establishing good government from
reflection choice or whether they are
forever destined to depend upon their
political circumstances on accident and
force there's truth this remark the
crisis at which we arrived may may with
propriety be regarded as the time when
the decision is to be made that is the
same circumstance we're and today we
have two things going for us one I think
people are increasingly objecting to
bureaucratic rule there's something
inhuman about being ruled by a National
Department of Motor Vehicles it's no
longer the case that individual
bureaucratic rule is not seen to be
connected to its other aspects is
incomprehensive Churchill once said that
people are easy to lead
but they are hard to drive and all of
this drives towards elections which is
say the place where the American people
can voice their opinions and show their
frustrations secondly we have faced
crises in the past there's still an old
woman since among the American people
this is a unique country despite the
fact that more and more of them in poll
after poll suggests and believe it is no
longer abiding by the consent of the
governed but the fact is that America's
principles its constitution the truths
proclaimed and etched in the human heart
are all still there for recovery we
sometimes have a sense of inevitability
that all is lost and that things can't
be turned Joseph Warren who was in
Boston after the battles of Concord in
the American revolutionaries came back
to oppose the British who had taken up
force there it was in charge of the
defenses of Boston into the face of the
English he of course went and fought at
the Battle of Bunker Hill that are
called breed skill more accurately and
the British attacked them not once not
twice but three times before the
American defenses were overwhelmed
Warren in that tack was immediately
killed by the British because they knew
what he was up to this is something he
wrote a month before he was killed our
streets are filled with armed men or
Harbor is crowded with ships of war but
these cannot intimidate us our liberty
must be preserved is far dearer than
life no longer could we reflect with
generous pride on the heroic actions of
our forefathers
if we but for a moment entertain the
thought of giving up our Liberty our
country is in danger but not to be
despaired of or enemies are numerous and
powerful but we have many friends
determining to be free and heaven and
earth will aid the resolution on you
depend the fortunes of America you were
to side the important question on which
rests the happiness and liberty of
millions unborn act worthy of yourselves
what we can do and what we hear in
Hillsdale especially focus on is
constantly pointing out why this country
is worthy of saving why it needs saving
and what could be done to save it trying
to put the other organs for
constitutional reconstruction and we can
do so all the while by forming and
shaping the character of our students
and of citizens and yes of statesmen who
will do so in the meantime we can better
ourselves so that we are worthy of the
founders Constitution thank
so we have time for some questions
before our next session Bob good
question what is Paul Ryan's North Star
let me go comment first I think one of
the most promising situations right now
is the fact that the fishery we've had
turnover in the house in terms of the
speakership but it's being driven now by
this discussion about rules the more
have thought about it it's a perfect
Madisonian argument which is say that
it's the structural rules which should
drive one towards an outcome and with a
loser with a less firmly directed
speakership I think there'll be a lot
more influenced by more people in the
house caucus in terms of Ryan himself I
think walk to wait and see the
speakership modern speakership is a very
difficult office the last person who is
speaker and later elected president nine
states was in 1844 you have to think
hard to think of the last speaker who
retired happy
having said that I think I would put him
down as an example of someone who is
grappling as best he can towards a
better constitutional outcome I think
the problem we face today yes there are
a lot of differences on particular on
tactics but there's a but the large
movement we have is back towards
reestablishing the rule of law and
establishing the authority of Congress
because only by re-establishing the
authority of Congress as an institution
can you actually revive the separation
of powers check the executive start
thinking forward about that what do you
do with the courts and in that sense
talking about the institution talking
about rules I think it's a place way to
do that 50 I'd be fair enough including
amplify the front part of your lecture
of saying that in many memories the oath
of fealty loyalty defensively Cain or
pure whereas here the others in the room
with provocation is to protect and then
that's right that's right so you even
during the American Revolution right
George Washington Institute's the first
oath but it's not an oath to him right
this even before the Constitution it's
an oath to the Continental Congress
absolutely and that's that's the
fundamental difference right in this
country or the regime and our oath is
oriented around that document the
principles it secures
you're on
is there anything to prevent us from
reducing
although all those good although Antonin
Scalia is getting pretty old
so the miracles of modern science has
kept them ticking there's no there's no
reason why you can't change the numbers
in the Supreme Court this is of course
what Franklin Roosevelt tried to do by
packing the court the problem is that it
would be extremely difficult not to see
that for a political move you I the so
whether you could get any interest in
that on either side I think would be
would be difficult I think the harder
question will be the we focus on all
this interest going on now in the House
of Representatives but I'm increasingly
worried about the Senate and the reason
there is again going back to a
structural point the Senate has headed
tradition not ground in the Constitution
itself but rules which is a modern
tradition of the filibuster it was it
meant to allow a minority of particular
centers for particular states to stop
legislation but it's now being used on a
regular everyday basis to stop anything
from happening from a Madisonian point
of view that I find that very
problematic and distressful that would
become a factor with Supreme Court
nominations I'm not sure how that plays
out I think the problem we have is that
Supreme Court nominations have become
increasingly for good reason focused on
philosophical understanding the
Constitution I think conservatism
there's one thing I would criticize has
been the appointment of Supreme Court
justices for all the great success of
original isms in law schools it is not
played out well when it comes to actual
judicial nominations I think that
actually has something to do with a
misunderstanding of constitutionalism
it's supposed to focus too much on
technical constitutionalism and not made
a broader for political
constitutionalism so I'm not sure how
good of a shape we are when it comes to
to our
at judicial nominations the best ones
and there are some very good ones on the
Supreme Court have almost oftentimes
come up because of chance not because of
them but because of the circumstances we
don't have a great track record so it's
all buddy to if you want to change
change the numbers in the court it's
perfectly legal to do so is perfectly
the cot the cool yeah the act of
Congress can change the numbers of the
court but you know you decrease or
increase it a little bit I'm not sure
whose advantage that will play out too
Carson foreground observations of all
the candidates themselves particularly
of a side which if any of you would seem
that understand hey all I not to get
partisan it's you know the ones that are
doing so they're trying to do so I mean
I think probably Ted Cruz he's a very
fine legal mind he studied these
questions probably the best example I
thaler problem we have is that the way
this debate is occurring is not allowing
for any serious discussion of anything
and that should be your biggest
disappointment I don't think it's that
we don't have I think they're the the
the the the candidates as opposed to
four years ago or better to better field
and yet it's becoming a complete debacle
the the objective my objective and the
objective of being here in Washington
for hillsdale college is not to pick
candidates it's not to pick judges for
that matter it's to take any of them and
try to make them better the best ones
will come forward we will help that but
then what you want or a lot of others to
help them it's always been the case that
in most politics going back at the very
beginning that most politicians look at
it as a politician and they don't have a
higher horizon it's all about getting
reelected talk about their self narrow
interests that's probably not going to
change anytime the future because of
human nature what you want to make sure
is that you have people who are capable
of giving them some direction and argue
their interest
point in a different direction so what
you do is you try to focus on the ones
that have the most promise and make them
better to guide the others and you start
a movement that's generally how politics
tends to work I don't questions are
trimmers you I don't know I don't know
think of I mean I'm generally opposed to
term limits and here's why think it
through if you have someone who's good
you should reelect them right and and if
there's one thing that the people have a
sovereign right to its decide who is
their elected representatives right well
not disagreeing with I just to go UK
it's Amy the filibuster I argue with the
friends around town with the filibuster
all the time what you should try to do
is try to get them to rethink these
things in the current circumstance you
need to rethink a lot of these questions
where there have been term limits
established at the state level they've
tended not to work very well in
California spinning goes up and they
figure out how to do rotation in office
right and also when you Institute term
limits who does that empower the staff
who become a permanent bureaucratic
establishment my general argument is it
the best thing we could do which i think
is the Madisonian argument is to make
things more political not less to make
things more partisan not less that's not
to say the political parties are
currently Institute are very good right
but you want to open up so there's a
public debate that has political
ramifications right and so trying to
affect folks on a particular solution
oftentimes we overlook the larger thing
that I think is the solution when
Madison and Jefferson founded the first
political parties in opposition to the
Federalists and the John Adams
administer
going into the election of 1800 what did
they do well they drugged their feet
they they made arguments right but more
is they organized and they made a case
to the American people that drove
towards the election of 1800 which they
won the presidency and control of
Congress Jenny a little bit but you were
going towards the Democratic nap is so
part of that and taken over by the
period of time and the Republican Party
is a 50 vessel now
it's taking shots at those who believe
in the family
bahlsen and so that's the reason Bob
their demise in my opinion and so is it
time for a new party and that wouldn't
help us in 2016 maybe which need that no
you're absolutely right the prom is that
one of the two political parties has
essentially become the party of the
state this is a very European tradition
right in Europe you shouldn't have a one
party that it's become this is the party
of this of the state of the
administration that's very much so today
we don't have an active two-party system
anymore and the other party the
Republicans I think or having very least
a very intense internal debate in which
one group I think wants to be the party
fantasy of the state or at least of in
power which tends to mitigate those who
want to push it in different direction
you have a large egg hopefully growing
segments within the Republicans who want
to change the direction of the country
the question is how do you go about
doing that the others problem you have
is that in a in the way the system is
designed way Madison design the system
it's designed for a two-party system all
right the this interesting back and
forth about rules in Congress versus a
strong speakership right that kind of
part of banners decline but also this
challenger some like Paul Ryan is you
have a very practical situation which is
that Congress is Congress and it's not
Parliament right what you say that it
won't work here to have a to try to turn
Congress indo of Parliament because
we're not a multi-party system right
majority rules this Congress a design
for a majority
that's your two-party system problem so
the idea of shaping the two parties is
the way that these movements normally
operate and I think it's still and until
you've come to the point where
everything is hopeless is still the way
those ideas will be translated Congress
the electoral college elections demand
what creating majorities is how they
design the system in order to ensure
that a majority of the American people
are with your changes which say that the
Madisonian answer i think the Madisonian
argument would be well we need to go out
and convince more Americans about the
direction of our country and why it
needs to be turned simple as that the
problem with third parties or the
problem with turning congressmen to
Parliament is that you also have the
challenge or the possibility of making
yourself more and more of a minority
party and you go into oblivion it's a
very fine line how you transition from
that's why historically in America we've
never had three parties or any
significance what happens is one party
tends to go away but they're replaced by
a new party which largely picks up most
of that first party that's a different
model that I think is more possible but
even then you would still have to
essentially reinvent the existing party
because of its structure that's not
anything else last question yes
well one thing we do is we make
hillsdale better and better and better
as a competitive model we've gone on to
we do a lot of more work online we've
started a set of charter schools to
affect education prior to going into
college and we're increasingly getting
involved in and want to be involved in
battles over things like ap history
standards and the common core
educational issues it's the same thing
however the the issue of what students
are being taught needs to be more front
and center but then you need to have an
alternative how to do it well and to
show what those arguments are so one of
the one that made airings about what
Hillsdale College can do is to is to
show how you can teach students
effectively these principles in an
intelligent way and we let publicly we
do that beyond that and then we come to
a place like this and make those same
arguments what I find is and I spent a
lot of my time working with staff who
work on the hill which are a year to out
of college they tend to be they don't
have had gone through those education
but what I find is they yearn for a
better argument they yearn to know these
arguments and these principles in this
history and they're very open to hearing
it if for no other reason because it's
something different than what they were
taught and they find it very attractive
and if we can present that argument in a
very aspirational sense
I think we can be much more successful
at it there are lots of their very few
hillsdale's but there are a lot of
places where there are centers on
college campuses Robbie George Robert
George up at Princeton University has
one of the most successful centers on a
college campus the James Madison program
up there you replicate that model as
much as you can but there are I think
there are more things that we could do
and and and can be doing to turn that
turn that around